So you've implemented sign-in
with Google technology
in your Android app, and you're
already seeing the benefits.
There's greater
user satisfaction,
there's easier security
infrastructure,
and there's less
danger from hackers.
Great, you're thinking, I'm set.
I'm good to go.
But wait.
What about my user data
that I keep on my servers?
How do I ensure that users
with Google sign-in storing
data with me are still secure?
Well, relax.
You don't need to
pull your hair out,
and you don't need
to be that guy.
I'm Laurence Moroney,
and in this video
I'll show you just
how easy it is for you
to secure your servers, too.
First, let's take a
look at what happens
when users sign into
your app, but then need
to provide identity to
your backend server.
Consider this scenario.
You've built an app
that delivers food
to them at their location.
They sign in to your app,
and your app gets their email
address as their identity.
But you store their address
and order preferences
in a database on your server.
Now, unless your
endpoint is protected
with an off mechanism,
attackers could potentially
access your user database by
guessing the email addresses
of the users.
And that's not hard.
This isn't just a
bad user experience.
It's a risk that customer data
can be stolen and misused.
Now, you can mitigate this by
getting a token from Google
when they sign in to your app,
and then passing this token
to your server instead.
Your server would then
validate the token,
and if it really did come
from your app, really
is for the desired user, and
really is a genuine Google
token, your server can
rest assured that it really
is your user making the call
and not a nefarious middleman.
In the case of a fake token
then being passed to the server,
when your server
sends it to Google,
it will be rejected
as counterfeit,
and your user data is safe.
So what are the
steps for doing this?
Well, first of all,
your Android app
can get a token after
signing in with Google.
And there's a great sample
that demonstrates that here.
It uses the
requestToken method when
calling the
GoogleSignInOptions objects.
And once it has the token,
it can post it over HTTPS
to your server, which will
then try to validate it.
Token verification is available
in the API client libraries
for Java, PHP,
Python, and Node.js.
Here's what the
server-side Java code might
look like to verify your token.
And it's really
as simple as that.
That's it for this DevByte.
Stay tuned to the Android
Developers channel on YouTube
for more, including how you can
write all the code to achieve
this kind of
sign-in and allowing
you to secure your servers.
I'm Laurence Moroney, and you're
going to go build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]